You're a honeycomb
You're
certainly a
powerful dopant You're constantly
awakening to new
abilities that exceed our expectations It's really interesting, but your weakness is that you're focused on attacking
That's how big your compound eyes are.
If you use them effectively, you should be able to see in all directions
.
If you could see it, you
would have noticed my strategy
Where was the shoulder fang I threw
earlier?
[Applause]
By the way, I praised you to buy time
.
That's why this is the true nature of the technique that slows down the opponent's movement
Small wings
like that There are some who can't see their wings when they vibrate at high speed this week This
invisible whole body grows all at once during battle
The special vibrations generated by the
vibration
put pressure on those around
me and
slowed down my movements.  Looks
like you've run out of tricks now Count your sins
Matsushima Drive
Tangsterewriter
[Music]